[Music]
thank you so much for coming out here
I'm delighted to meet you I'm so excited
to talk to you thank you welcome to our
little slice of heaven out here this is
the this is the veil of Los Angeles if
that's a thing can that be a thing it
can be a thing we'll make it a thing
well and we have a special guest here
with Lucy right Lucy she broke her arm
or hit by a car so well her cast is very
cute Thanks
how does she get hit by a car hmm yeah
she was chasing after any animal on Oh
chase right after the wheel of a car
poor girl
yeah well as I said all dogs welcome
here thank you so cool well I think the
best way to kind of dig into this is I'm
interested in what you're doing right
now like you you have a house in Los
Angeles right yeah so do you spend some
of your time living out here yeah it's
been part time here and part time in
Colorado and really most of my time on
the road for racing but I love it you
know it's it's difficult I've always
been chasing winter so it's nice to have
a place that's warm that I can come back
to and my dogs love it here so cool yeah
so typically you would be going to South
America during the warmer months here
right so yeah chasing snow year-round
yep so I went to Chile a few weeks ago
and normally we go to New Zealand but I
didn't go this year and yeah we're just
constantly chasing chasing the snow and
you know usually October is when we go
to Europe and then November we're
starting training again in Colorado so
it's kind of non-stop yeah we just have
a few months off in the summer where
we're working out in the gym what are
you training for right now I mean this
is gonna be my last season on the world
cup is that official I've kind of said
it a couple times but no one really
seems to believe me so I'm just gonna
repeat myself that I'm retiring and you
know so I'm just I'm really gonna look
to enjoy this last season and
I'm hoping to break the World Cup win
record which is 86 and I try T to
Division 2 right now right yeah so
that's my big goal
there's also World Championships in
Sweden in February but I really just
want to enjoy this last season and and
have fun with it and you know if I break
it great if not you know I've had a
great career and I'm just ready to do
something different that's a healthy
perspective yeah I mean it didn't start
off that way but is now gotten to the
healthy part well it's got to be
interesting how it's all evolved for you
because as a young person you can just
train and nap and life is very contained
and simple and you live a very large
life right now you've got a ton of
competing interests and all different
kinds of things that you could be doing
I would imagine you have to say no to a
lot of stuff and fun opportunities but
based on like looking at your Instagram
which is a terrible barometer Cote
raining really hard and then like having
fun and then like lots of dog stuff I
mean most of my life right now still
revolves around you know preparing for
the ski season and being in the gym and
I've tried to you know have more fun
with it and do interesting things do
like contests and a bunch of balanced
stuff make it more fun but yeah there
are definitely a lot of opportunities
that are coming my way and it's hard to
kind of decide what to do and you know
it's definitely a pivot point in my life
and transition period and I can't say
that I know exactly you know the main
focus of what I'll be doing next but I
have a lot of really interesting and
cool opportunities so I'm excited about
the future it's really weird to still
think about life without ski racing yeah
but you know I know physically I just
can't do it anymore and the grind
mentally of grinding physically mm-hmm
takes its toll yeah yeah
well there's that rumor sir
going around that the rock is going to
show you around Hollywood fellow under
Under Armour athlete teammate well he
does that happen yet yeah I mean I've
definitely kind of leaned on him as a
kind of a mentor and his road to success
is pretty incredible I mean he's the
world's greatest mentor yes you could
have him as a mentor I mean we could all
be so much yeah right so I I'm just like
what you know anytime I have a question
I just asked him and and you know I I
went on set with him on ballers and I in
between takes I was just you know
hammering him with questions and and
then he'd go and do his line you know
super easy then take a break and I'd you
know continue to ring him but I think
that you know it's definitely something
that I would be interested in doing I'm
not sure if I'd be great at it but he
seems to think that I will be so because
you know what we have the same mentality
of just hard work and I think that you
know if I have that opportunity I'd work
really hard to be good at it so well
you're both grinders yes for sure finale
you know definitely grinder and I don't
know where that guy's source of energy
comes from it has to be lemon as I said
I'm like I need at least like eight or
nine hours of sleep you know I don't
know how you survive on this grind that
you have going and he's like no I get
you know six or seven hours like you
wake up at 3:00 a.m. right every day I
don't know what math you're doing but
crazy inspirational that he'll like fly
all the way to Europe from LA and then
arrive at like 3:00 in the morning and
immediately go work out and you know
it's really cool yeah I love it but
before that you're still training right
now yeah and you're trying to balance
all of that with all the fancy stuff
that you get to do what is that training
look like and how do you you know
maintain that level of intensity and
focus like I know you're a grinder it's
like your disposition it's probably not
hard for you but at the same time it is
different than when you were 18 19 years
old yeah it's a lot different I mean
just based on my injuries it makes
things
it's so much harder you know my workouts
are all kind of modified to just do what
I can do basically you know I I can't
jump I can't running you know I can't
jump no you get run come on
I was I was able to jump until recently
and now it's just I'm I'm bone-on-bone
whining so I just it's it's it's had
enough and you know you stop doing that
I've never been good at running so like
you let's let's be honest but you're on
the bike a lot right you're on the bike
yeah every day yeah well I mean you ride
outdoors too or just all in Colorado I
can't say that Los Angeles is the best
place for Road biking if you come up
here it's pretty good but it's hundred
degrees yeah all right now well it's not
okay Brandon yeah it's almost ski season
yeah yeah but yeah it's I love I love
biking outside you know in the mountains
it's it's pretty incredible in Colorado
but it can get really monotonous you
know and then you know before I ski you
have to warm up my knee and workout for
like 45 minutes you know it's a it's
just a process it's not even remotely
close to what I did when I was you know
18 19 years old I used to just get up
and go and you get on the hill and you
just bomb down the mountain and you know
that's it and now it's like this whole
long process because I'm old you're
talking to somebody who's 52 like I get
it I know you're like you love bein you
do you like try usually do triathlons as
of you're crazy I'm a grinder but I'm
like you know my level of grind isn't
anything like yours you know and and I
think and and certainly you know I
haven't had I haven't sustained the kind
of injuries that you've had I mean it's
it's impossible to even keep track of
all the things that you've had to
weather through like I mean how many
pins and screws do you have in your body
I mean you got scars all over you I mean
this is like you know the the laundry
list of injuries that you've had would
have just ended the career of most
people or at least sideline them for
much longer than you but you've you've
had this ability to always come back
always come back always come back like
always overcome the obstacle and like
continue to show up show up show up well
I mean I think you know it's hard to
beat the person that never gives up you
know it's just I have a passion for what
I do
and you know if their ups and downs
everyone has their obstacles they have
to face
maybe mine are worse than most but not
the worst that others have had so you
know I always try to keep things in
perspective and understand that I am
still really lucky to be able to do what
I do and I just work as hard as I can
and if I'm successful after injury then
great if not I'm still doing what I love
so you know to me there is no downside
and in trying your best was there ever a
moment after sustaining one of these
injuries where you just thought like
that's it I'm done my arm injury was
pretty bad because I couldn't use my
right that was in 16 right yeah yeah so
you lost the feeling in your hand for
quite a while yeah for about two months
I I couldn't move my hand I and I
thought you know not only am I not
skiing again but I'm not gonna be able
to eat food or sign mine I couldn't sign
my name I couldn't write the alphabet I
could really hold a pencil uh-huh so how
long did it take before the feeling came
back I started to be able to move my
hand like move the fingers after about a
month and then I again like full
strength I'd probably like four or five
months but it was really scary because
your knee it's you know it's it's your
knee you're gonna get better you just
have to be patient do the work and it'll
turn around
but with my hand you know they didn't
they couldn't really give me a an
estimate they're like we don't know
could get better could not get better
you could have no function on your hand
ever again you know and that was a
pretty scary because your nerves have to
regenerate right and grow and they grow
very very slowly oh yeah so did you
continue to train throughout that or
what attention you like tape your hand
to the ski poles right so I was skiing
like I when my hand got cold I lost a
bit of feeling and I just dropped my
pole a couple times and so to me it's
not worth you know losing a race because
I simply dropped my poles I just duct
tape it to my hand and you know moved on
well I think that that you know what
really I mean certainly you're
unbelievably talented and you've been at
the top of your game for for so long but
I think people who who don't really
understand or know that much about you
just think oh well she's the greatest
skier of all time like she's out there
she just wins everything constantly but
when you really drill down into your
career it's it's like you know it's like
high highs and low lows consistently
throughout right it's just it's marked
with all a million setbacks way more
than you know somebody you know I've
followed your career and then I started
to like really read more you know dive
into the details of it and I was like oh
my god like you've really had to sink
you sank low and you've constantly come
back and come back and come back so I'm
interested in like the mindset required
to do something like that because if I
had to you know if somebody asked me
like what distinguishes Lindsey Vonn
from everybody else I think it's what's
between your ears as much as anything
else yeah I mean obviously you have to
be willing to put the work in but I
think the will to be able to push
yourself to overcome things is is
something that you can't teach you know
you either have it or you don't and
you're either willing to sacrifice
things and and push yourself or you're
not and what is it like how do you
define that I don't know I mean I think
there's it's you know it's an element of
grit that you know and I've talked with
several people about this I it's hard to
really say you know what is grit and and
how do you get it is it'll look
something that you learn can you teach
it I don't think you can I think I mean
I think I learned definitely from my
grandfather and my father on you know
what work is and you know you just shut
up and do the job you know there's
there's no complaining there's there's
no reason to you know you could have
life a lot worse than what you do so you
know you're given a task and you just
have to accomplish it no matter what so
I think there's an element of that
that's ingrained in me from from those
two figures in my life but I think it's
also that I'm just passionate about ski
racing you know I think if you're
passionate about something and you're
willing to you know push yourself that
hard you're willing to go the extra mile
that maybe others wouldn't it's and it's
not just about skiing it's really about
anything yeah you know most the people
that are highly successful are not the
best at what they do or the most
talented at what they do but they're
willing to work harder than everybody
else yeah and how do you maintain that
level of passion over the years and
years and years it has to like wax and
wane right there's got to be moments
where you're like not feeling so
passionate right now I mean there are
definitely times when you wake up you
know at 4:00 or 5:00 in the morning and
it's you know it's not fun to do that
but whenever I'm on the mountain I
really enjoy it and there's I think it's
also at this point a way of therapy for
me you know with everything that goes on
in my life I think that ski racing is my
outlet you know it's the one place where
you know I can control everything and
and I have the freedom to do what I want
and it's a it's a weird image to think
about life without that therapy you know
I don't really know that's a that's
probably not a good thing
but you're so involved in so many other
things all right worried about
necessarily it's just you know that's
where I think the passion comes from is
because that's racing is like my place
you know it's it's where I'm the
happiest and that's why it's easy for me
to keep pushing to get back to it
because it just makes me happy what do
you think it is that that distinguishes
a good ski racer from a great ski racer
like what is the what is like the one
attribute of that specific discipline
that is crucial to reach you know the
highest level of the sport that might be
different from
playing basketball or you know any other
given discipline I think there's an
element of fear that you just can't have
if you want to be highly successful at
ski racing you know you have to be
willing to crash and crash hard and get
back up and keep doing it you know it's
not like basketball where you know okay
you're running into some guy you get an
elbow to the face that's not the same as
you know crashing at 85 miles an hour
and I I just think that it's it's again
it's something that you either have or
you don't and I think I've always been
the person that's really crazy and I
I've never had that fear and and even
since I was you know nine years old I
was skiing downhill and everyone thought
I was nuts but right you were like me it
was like a kamikaze you feel like day
one it's crazy yeah I mean I think it is
true like you either have that or you
don't but if you have it you can still
lose it and as somebody who's suffered
these crazy injuries and horrible
crashes a normal person would would
would probably have even if it's just
the slightest bit of hesitation right
that's the difference between podium and
you know 50th place or you know it's its
measured in you know second so even that
that like almost instinctual impulsive
like you know reaction that makes you
hold back just a little bit because your
your leg bent the wrong way the last
time you made a move you know how do you
override that and and still get into
that zone where that is not a factor in
how you're making those tiny little
decisions
mm-hmm I don't know I mean it's I think
most people that have been injured and
say they do have that hesitation and it
takes a while to get over it I for some
reason don't have that which is maybe
why crash so often but I just write like
she never learns oh yeah
like what's wrong with me I just don't I
don't know I don't see the point and
being afraid because if you're afraid
and you have that hesitation then you're
not gonna win races anyways so I try to
look at it from like a logical
perspective but I mean it's not logical
though it's completely a function of
your unconscious mind I think I think
it's weird yeah it's awkward to even ask
these questions because I your son this
is just who you are right like and
you're being asked to explain it like it
doesn't it's like that's actually a
question I get asked a lot and then it's
always a difficult one for me to answer
because I don't really know why and the
way I am right but that is what I am
this is yeah you've never been you don't
know what it's like to be right yeah
it's it's interesting I mean cuz when I
think about downhill ski racing which is
it disappoints so different than than
anything that you know I ski but that
you know that I specialize in its you're
moving so quickly and you're making
these decisions that are so tiny but you
have to be forecasting down the mountain
and making decisions that are impacting
what you're gonna do three seconds later
when you get down there like the level
of like it's all happening so quickly
and there and there and every little
thing is so tiny right yeah I mean it's
very similar to car racing but you're
not you don't have the protection of a
car uh-huh you know you I think it's
also to once you're adapted to going
that fast things tend to slow down you
know you're able to see things more
clearly because that seems to be a
normal speed mm-hmm
you know it's and I think there's a lot
with me that's very instinctual you know
my reactions are as planned as possible
but at the same time when you're going
that fast you are relying on your
instincts and you know thankfully I
think for the most part I have pretty
good ones but you know what I'm trying
to win
sometimes I make the wrong ones and
right and then I crash well you know you
if you're going for it you know it's
gonna happen right that's the thing I
mean I'd I'd rather you know I'd rather
go down trying to win then you know get
safe with a finish line in last place
you know I I just want to push myself
and see what I'm capable of
yeah so how many races are you doing
this season like you got to get your at
82 you want to get to 86 that's you need
four more wins how many chances at that
it's got to be 20-something oh wow okay
down-home super-g races there's maybe 18
so something like that there's like nine
or ten of each discipline last year I
got five wins which was a notic I mean
it was pretty good but it wasn't like a
crazy good year for me so but I think
you know the more I just focus on
enjoying my last season and just kind of
going out with a bang and not really
focusing on that record I think the
better off I'll be yeah so you're trying
not to think too much about that
overthinking is a really no yeah yeah
well speaking of that I mean how do you
kind of mentally prepare and visualize a
race like when you're in the gate like
are you at a blank do you do formal
practices where you visualize every
aspect of going down that mountain so
that when you show up it's just you're
you're kind of like just presence or how
does that work for you yeah so we have
in downhill we usually have one or two
training runs where we get to run the
course and normal I'll have a pretty
good idea of you know what I want to do
I'll know the line I'll be able to
visualize it you know at least a hundred
times leading up to the race and when I
get in the starting gate then I don't
really have to think about it because
it's already ingrained in my mind and a
lot of the times these tracks too is
that it's the same course that it's been
for the last ten years fifteen years
doing this your whole life yeah so you
know a lot of times I probably don't
even need to look at the course to know
exactly what I need to do
but you know like I said it's it's
having that plan and being confident in
what you're doing but then at the end of
the day when you're in the course you
have to have those instincts to be able
to react because you could hit you know
a patch of icy snow or you know the
lights flat and you can't see a bump and
you know you go offline and and then you
know you're scrambling and you have to
make those instantaneous decisions that
will determine whether you win or lose
the race yeah
how important are our mentors to you I
mean your dad your grandfather
we're obviously instrumental and you
becoming a skier in the first place and
then you meet Picabo and that was a big
moment for you but where you're at right
now do you still have people in your
life that you look to for guidance and
different areas like how does that work
and how do you think about that yeah I
definitely do I mean I think that you
know from an athletic perspective you
know there's obviously the people like
Roger Federer and Serena and you know I
still look to people people like Picabo
you know as as my idol but I think more
so it's like my friends and my family
that keep me grounded that's most
important to me at this point I know you
know I know how to ski I know that part
of my life but a lot of the time I just
need people to be real with me yeah and
kind of keep me grounded and and that's
how I'm able to stay the same person you
know I and I'm I'm happy with who I am I
don't want to change who I am so it's
really important for me to be around
those stable people that really can
support me the way I need it it would be
so easy for you to surround yourself
with a ton of people that just tell you
how awesome you are all the time yeah
especially in this town you know and
then you know fast forward one year from
unless you have the better own friends
yeah well it's a big city I mean la is a
very easy target to make fun of and
there's certainly lots of things wrong
with it but there's all kinds of people
here anime
people doing incredible things that are
influencing culture and I think it's a
really cool place to live I think it
just takes a little bit longer to find
your tribe here yeah was somewhere else
yeah I mean yeah so I mean that kind of
naturally leads us into this you know
conversation about you as as a role
model I mean clearly you're a role model
to a lot of people a lot of young women
does that influence how you make
decisions like how do you kind of
shoulder that sense of responsibility
yeah definitely I mean I've I've kind of
always felt that level of responsibility
because I remember when I was looking up
to Picabo and how much of an impact she
had on me and so when now the roles are
reversed I definitely have always felt
that you know I need to conduct myself
in a certain way that you know not only
my family would approve of but one of
the young girls and kids that look up to
me what approve of as well so I started
my foundation as well and 2015 and and
our mission is to empower inspire young
girls I've got cams and scholarships and
programs and and you know that's
something that's really important to me
you know being able to do something
positive with the position that I'm in
mm-hmm you know if I'm I don't want to
be just a ski racer you know I want to
have a positive impact on the world and
you know help these kids accomplish
their dreams and help them you know try
to be healthy and happy and positive
productive humans yeah that's cool so
it's scholarships for young women too
for athletes only or all different kinds
of girls or generally there are some
scholarships we can give out to athletes
but it's mostly educational based
programs like stem all right it's done
program yeah yeah yeah there's a couple
of random things like a girl wanted to
be a racecar driver and she couldn't get
in because she's a girl and you know she
needed extra help there's there's you
know a couple of really interesting
stories in there but yeah it's a very
diverse group and I never want to close
a door to you know anyone so if
I can help I will yeah that's cool well
it's such an amazing moment right now
for women and female empowerment and you
know something I say on the podcast all
the time is that there's no shortage of
amazing women doing incredible things
they're role models everywhere we just
don't do a very good job of shining a
spotlight on them as well as we could
and should but I feel like recent events
over the course of the past year have
really shifted the ballast of that and
now we're we're seeing so much more
attention and respect for incredible
women who are you know putting their
stamp on on culture in positive ways
which is really cool yeah but I think
you know on that on that subject of
responsibility I mean it's got to be
difficult for you with the name that you
have and the profile that you have like
navigating the treacherous waters of
social media and like all the you know
nonsense that goes on there I mean
there's been you know well-documented
dramas a Hugh had whether through all of
that like how do you do you just
compartmentalize that or you like not
read mentions or how do you like deal
with the noise so that you can stay
focused on what it is that you're trying
to accomplish and like stay positive
it's hard all that nonsense out there
it's really hard I think when I'm skiing
you know in season it's a little bit
easier because I have that outlet of
skiing and I don't really think twice
about what people say it's mostly in
this summer that I have a harder time
with it you have more time on your hands
and I know I'm on the bike for a few
hours and never a good idea that's a bad
idea and you know before the Olympics it
was you know I it was there's a lot of
death threats and it was just like
pretty crazy but you know I try to
remember I try to think about like you
know who these people are and and that
they're not important people in my life
and they don't care about me so why
should I care about them mm-hmm you know
and and that's a hard thing to keep in
perspective because
does tear you down you know it it it is
a hard hard and harsh world to live in
these days so I just do the best I can
some days it affects me more than others
but I try really hard not to read things
it's so insane that you had to that you
received death threats I mean is so
crazy I hope you have a cliff and die I
hope you're in a wheelchair the rest
your life that's just keyboard warriors
yeah you know every time I fell they're
like there you go that's karma like
you're a terrible person so crazy world
that we live in my family loves me
yeah matter it is true though I mean it
is you know it is true so what does it
tell me walk me through your training
routine now cuz you're a beast huh
real Gold's this morning I always a
grand pose yeah I had I hate having to
be traffic I have to wake up so early
I'm usually I go work out the Red Bull
gym but yeah normally in the mornings
it's like you know I've got my my warmup
my mobility my knee warm up and then I
do core lifting balance then the
afternoon is biking mm-hmm
so two days I got the five days a week
or something like that uh you got the
peloton yeah I don't actually use the
classes most of the time though it's
kind of counterintuitive though they
have those ones where you can ride like
in through the city yeah yeah I like I
rode the Hawaii yeah I just you know my
trainer has a program and you know like
I said it's difficult because I can't do
a lot of things that I used to do and
then I actually really need to do but we
modify things to accommodate for my
limitations yeah with my knee but like
core strength explosive power type
exercises free weights like that's the
focus of it right a lot of core you know
rotational stability a lot of glute work
you know cleans power cleans a lot of
squats deadlifts yeah
like kind of the basic you know core
router exercises and then once you get
to the mountain then it does it just
become a combination of skiing plus all
of that yeah it's like a more toned down
version of my workouts because most of
my energy is going to my skiing but it's
hard on the road when you're traveling
and racing because you don't always have
the energy to be able to do the lifting
sessions but you really need to do the
lifting sessions like I have a problem
during the season I tend to get really
skinny because I just can't maintain
that same level of weight lifting and
muscle mass well you're just constantly
traveling from one venue to the next
right and also stressed yeah yeah the
very romantic picture of what that's
actually like there's probably a lot of
people who think you're just you're
cruising around in a private jet
everywhere it's like it's hard it's
ignite it's an eye drive I mean in
Europe you know you drive you race you
know Friday Saturday Sunday you get in
the car you pack up Sunday night drive
six hours is there like a bus or do you
drive yourself how does that work is
you're a team but you're not really yeah
we're not really we yeah we're we're not
we almost all of us have our own cars
Toyota's and then we just I'm like I've
got so much crap that I just fill mine
to the top and then Lucy's my passenger
so she goes to Europe with you oh yeah
yeah
I mean it's difficult you know when when
you're you know always by yourself you
know you're in the car by yourself and
then you get to the hotel you always
come home to an empty hotel room it's
pretty depressing so I got Lucy to help
me with that
it's always nice to have a friendly face
doesn't matter if I crash or fi1 she's
always happy to see me and right I wish
I could traveling with my two big dogs
but you know they're really big so where
did they do they live here in LA or in
Vail in Colorado
yes
okay yeah he takes care of them when I'm
not around uh-huh
yeah you got a hole you got a bunch of
brothers and sisters right yeah I four
two brothers and two sisters the lower
three are triplets the youngest Wow so
you you grew up in Minnesota and then
the whole family moved to Vail yeah to
support you all right
that's a lot of pressure on a little kid
it was a lot yeah and and you know I'm
really thankful and lucky that I have
such good siblings you know none of them
have resented me or you know have held
it over me that we moved out there I
mean they all lost their friends you
know we call it were they I was like 12
13 so the triplets were six seven oh
well they're so young I mean and Karen
was Karen was 10 11 mm-hmm they didn't
really matter any well with the kids
there so it was a pretty tough
transition did you feel like you had to
succeed to legitimize that for the
family yeah of course yeah and it was
weird it was a weird thing like like you
didn't realize you were moving until you
didn't actually already moved or
something your parents were like okay
we're here yeah they were going on
vacation and then we got there and it
was like surprise we're never going home
uh-huh and your grandfather was a ski
jumper right and then jumper dad was a
skier yeah my dad was a racer my dad was
also he also played football my
grandfather played offense and defense
football he was a boxer he run track and
field he was like yeah definitely have
good genetics in that sense but I can't
say I'm like really as athletic as they
are I have a really good feel for the
snow but I'm not you know I can't play a
basketball I can't run like I am you
know any ball sports and I haven't have
no chance yeah but would you rather be
pretty good at a whole bunch of sport
rather but I don't rather have what I
have
my siblings are so my sister just ran in
the Chicago Marathon mmm really proud of
her first kill doubt ever to run more
than like two miles at one time
uh-huh so it's like you're like
Norwegian now right yeah but we don't be
like cross luxury skiers no no we are
like you know we're not racehorses we
were Clydesdales we are built for slow
and steady labor you know says the woman
who skis down the mountain at like 85
miles now I'm like I'm like a sturdy
strong like train just barreling down
the mountain you know it's like we're
not built for you know I am NOT gonna
like you
I am NOT built for noone for endurance
yeah but I mean I can't do anything like
you do it so it's at all it's all it's
all right but well so your sister ran
the marathon
did everybody ski growing aki growing up
yeah my aunt my one brother Reid was
really the only one that loved ski
racing the rest of them just could care
less my sister Karen marathoner she only
one races if we bribed her with hot
chocolate at the finish you know were
like we got a hot chocolate waiting for
you with marshmallows and she'd be like
yay maybe I could get her yeah or like
she had to go the bathroom I was like no
you gotta hold it in and then she's like
mm-hmm
and it sounds like your dad I mean it
was pretty intense with your dad yeah I
mean my dad seemed like my grandfather's
like you know they demanded a certain
level of dedication and you know
intensity it's all over it is you're
gonna do you have to have pride in what
you do and do it to the best of your
ability so if you didn't live up to your
own standard then you know it was
definitely not an easy household to live
in but I think that it was really good
because it made us better people I can't
say at the time that I felt that way
necessarily all the time but but those
are important life lessons that serve
you well later in law I mean we all
turned out really well so you know I
think that he did a good job yeah and
now we're that pendulum has swung very
far in the other direction where
everybody gets a medal and we're all
perfect snowflakes
all of that yeah I did not agree with
that so yeah this is we'll see what what
the Olympic team and 2032 looks like
with that everyone gets a gold I
wouldn't be surprised you know so I'm
interested in how it works with with all
the crazy doping controls that are going
on right now like I had Ryan Fogle in
here the director of Icarus did you see
that movie
unfortunately you did so what is it
what's your reaction to that like it's
crazy I mean I you know never I had
suspicions that's you know some people
and in my sport you know may or may not
have done something but it's really
scary to see that because it's been
happening for clearly a very long period
of time and you know it's been it's a
systemic problem and I don't think that
they probably have fixed it even with
what they've done to reprimand Russia
yeah but it's it's just scary to think
of how if you really if you really want
to get away with it you can and I'm sure
people want to win badly enough to where
you know they'll do something but for me
like I'm scared to even I don't even
take you know vitamin C like I'm scared
to take anything like anything that I do
take like a protein powder you know has
to be NSF certified yeah and so like for
me it's been a really big problem over
my career to trust anything that I'm
taking like I have to send like if I'm
taking any sort of supplement I have to
send the whole batch out to get it
tested and certified and so it's pretty
exciting for me now to be able to be at
this point in my career where kind of in
the same direction that like my book is
you know strong is a new beautiful and
and I think that's another part of my
legacy that is really important to me
trying to allow people to understand
what they're doing so that they can live
healthier lives and
happier I mean I don't I never liked
working out but until I accepted it and
and you know enjoyed it now I feel like
I need it you know it makes me feel
better I'm happier when I work out and
you know that's something that I want to
share with people and and help them find
that as well and find just their own way
to be happier it is so difficult for an
athlete of your stature to navigate
what's okay to eat and not I mean every
Olympic athlete that I know like they
just stay away from all supplements
altogether because it's just too
terrifying yeah you are hearing about
athletes that that the tests dirty and
it turns out like they had a tainted
protein powder or something like that
like you just can't trust anything and I
know a little bit about how those labs
work where a lot of these companies are
having their products manufactured and
there's so much contamination and
there's very little oversight and
there's no regulation like you have no
idea what's going on there something you
can't trust that what it says on the
label is actually what's in there and if
you were to take it to a lab and test it
I can almost guarantee you that it will
look very different than what that
Nutrition Facts label says exactly and
yeah like you said I mean as an athlete
it's it's scary to even like I don't
even want to touch I don't even look at
it you know those those like anything
you find in like a you know health food
store none of that stuff is most likely
what it says it is you know and the
percentage of vitamins and supplements
that are tainted or you know have
products and their ingredients and them
that aren't actually what says on the
label is like so high because they're
cross producing their conversations
multitude of lines in these facilities
where all different kinds of products
are getting made using the same
equipment yeah you know I've been
approached by a lot of different
companies you know throughout my career
and I I know there are some athletes
maybe not Olympic athletes but some
athletes that have you know more lenient
restrictions on their their doping
rules you know they've promoted other
companies but I just have never felt
comfortable you know st. putting my name
on a product you know I don't wanna tell
the people tell the public to be taking
something that I wouldn't even take you
know that I can't trust what's in it you
know it's it's about leading a healthy
lifestyle life is a workout and you know
like I said I I don't I've never trusted
taking anything what do you think people
most misunderstand about you I mean
there's so much press out there people
have to be getting it wrong all the time
yeah I mean I think it just in general
you know anyone in the spotlight has you
know there's this perception that's out
there you know they're you know I think
most people don't know that I have
depression and you know they're like oh
you're successful and you're pretty and
whatever and it's like why aren't you
happy and all those things don't equal
happiness you know because I'm
successful doesn't mean that I'm happy
it's important for me to surround myself
with with you know the people that I
love that make me happy and that's you
know that's something that keeps me
grounded and keeps me going but I just
hate the misconception that like you
know my life's perfect and I'm happy and
everything's like Instagram right it's
all perfect yeah well if those people
had just crashed one of the times that
you could how does the how does the
depression work how does that manifest
um I don't know I mean I've had it I've
I've been taking medicine for it since I
was like 18 or 19 mm-hmm
but you know it definitely is more
difficult when I'm injured i I just take
medicine
you know the whole everyday because I
you know it's not worth it's not like
you know you're depressed you're gonna
take an Advil
you know it's like it's not you have to
be consistent about how you're you're
taking it and and I obviously see
therapists and and that's important it
definitely helps me because it's
difficult to talk about you know some of
the things
life because I don't feel like many
people understand it and I always feel
like I'm complaining mm-hmm but they're
not allowed to complain you know I mean
you know it's to do that you know
because you live this life you feel you
know yeah what I'm saying is that that
boxes you into like this prison where
you feel like you just can't be who you
you can't be honest about your your real
life experience because people will
judge you for that because you've you
know been privileged to have experiences
that most people will never get to yeah
and that's that's tough and I am I
understand where they're coming from
because you know I can see it from that
side as well but I do have my issues and
you know it's definitely difficult
sometimes and very I'd say though the
hardest thing about what I do is just
being lonely you know I'm on the road a
lot and in an empty hotel and in an
empty house and you know I'm lucky that
I have a really great boyfriend and you
know I have three dogs and I have a
great family and people that support me
but it doesn't take away from the fact
that I am still alone and I do feel that
really deep loneliness that that really
affects me a lot of the time and so it's
something that I am working on and all
of that everything kind of rides on your
shoulders the foundation these
relationships with all of these sponsors
I mean you're alone in a hotel room and
some village in Europe but there's a
whole machine that's kind of depending
upon you to continually produce produce
produce yeah that's a hard part it's
like I just realized that when Lucy got
run over by a car it was like you know I
have all these things that I have to do
and and if I can't do them I don't know
what happens like that you know the
whole system implodes and you know I had
to take a week off to you know take her
to surgery and I had to cancel all these
things and it was just kind of an
interesting realization that you know I
can't stop and I'm used to grinding so
it's you know it's me you know
stop anyway but still it was like well
you know there are a lot of things in
motion that you know I have to keep in
motion and I can't just stop doing them
yeah a lot of people rely on me and
there is a lot of feeling that I can't
let anyone down
you know yeah well those are external
pressures I mean what does it look like
on the inside like what what is it you
know behind all of this that's like
driving you like is it I mean and you
can say oh you know I just I want to be
the best version of myself or you know I
like to win or whatever but like what's
beneath that like what is really like
the pilot light that is like igniting
this whole thing that keeps you like on
this constant grind forward to like
excel I think it has to do with me not
being not ever being satisfied I feel
like I can do better and it's also I
think a feeling I'm not being good
enough you know somehow you know one win
isn't enough I need to win too and you
know that I'm never complacent you know
I'm never satisfied with what I have you
know I just have the always have that
urge to keep going you know I want
something more do something that
someone's never done before you know try
something new you know start my own
company you know work with people that
no one else has worked with it's like
you know I just have this Drive that
makes me want to just do be better and
it's not I probably is for mixed reasons
you know like from my from you know
family growing up and don't you know
there's I'm sure there's a lot of
psychological insecurities and all of
that these things that we all share as
human beings I mean I don't know of
course that if you're somebody who who
you know one you know this many wins is
never enough you know when you get that
86 or 87 or 88 it's still not going to
be
my piece right you that's why it's
Maddie you gotta you gotta like that's
an inside job oh yeah definitely an
inside job and and it's something that
I've had to kind of realize and work
through and that's why I've just said it
doesn't matter what the season holds
whether I win or I don't win all right
break the record or write down this is
just it you know I need to kind of you
know really enjoy it and soak it all in
for the last time and then I need to you
know just literally move forward yeah
start something new that's when you call
the rock some I called me Dwayne what do
they do now where are you I've got this
script sitting right here Lindsay come
on over cool well we got to wrap this up
I want to be conscious of your time
thanks I got one more workout today so
do you what are you doing I gotta go
home and ride the bike do you yeah a
peloton peloton yeah do you take my girl
Robin are Zhaan's class I don't take any
class you should die wrong in secret
Robin's a caller I'm definitely going
through you and I don't actually have to
follow my stupid program uh-huh but but
now like Hawaii I've gone right over
there you could use it if you want
Oh points Thanks delightful to talk to
you I wish you well when do you leave
for Europe I we have a couple of races
here and well in Canada first and then
I'll go over like the third or fourth of
December and then you're there for how
long
I'll come home for Christmas thankfully
we have a nice little break and then I'm
gone for like January for every March
uh-huh and then that's it that's a wrap
and then it's done so then it's party
time
cool Lindsay it's a pleasure talking to
you yeah how do you feel I feel great
how do you feel like therapy session and
I think dude I don't need therapy there
you go thank you
good well I serve that role for you I'm
here anytime for you you're easy to find
on the Internet
everywhere people are not already
following you they should and come back
and talk to me again sometime I well
cool sounds good pleasure appreciate
that piece
[Music]